this is the first time this season we're
going to see these two in the regular
season this is a team of history we're
talking about 73 wins what's it in gold
it stayed up brave but 11-point
turnaround here on the bird I don't know
if Cleveland can win a game playing the
way they're playing they've run into a
team that has total confidence and just
a total understanding of how to
dismantle and beat the Cavaliers they
believe in what they're doing where they
going and where they've been before you
guys know the numbers I have to give you
right now
seems to the 3:1 liters 223 and 10
all-time in the playoffs and 32 and OH
in the NBA fun
I mean guys talk trash in this league
all the time you know I'm just kind of
shocked some guys take it so personal
I guess his feelings just got hurt
whatever what place
to change
my king
what a sparkling performance tonight
from Kyrie Irving Irving
but James
sighs inside
one of the greatest
as we get set for Game six and here in
this city they're saying this is the
biggest game
Chai's history and one of the biggest
nights in the city sports history frozen
and to smith smith ally of the james
Larry
first time and predicting before the
game that I really have no clue and I
think you see a classic game seven James
offensive weapon
shumpert
Barbossa - James
[Music]
urban and furry
that's over Cleveland is a
be a champion it's all us against all
odds
in this way oh we didn't read the books
the first team ever to come back from a
3-1 deficit this especially
congratulations you're the first team in
the history of the NBA to come back from
the 3-1 deficit in the championship
the biggest stage game seven man I
wouldn't trade it for the world but
there was a reason why all of us were
put together there was a specific reason
why every single guys here the only
question that can ever be said about
this team is what's next I'm just one
man on one man with a what a plan would
have drive with determination always the
forever man I love all of y'all it's up
to Washington to celebrate the biggest
name biggest fish still out there in
Kevin Durant this is tough to kind of
swallow
he's meeting right now with the Clippers
it'll be a good image for us over the
summer and it's very impressive that
we've come back stronger the OKC seems
the best place if he was a free agent
somewhere else he'd say have to come to
Oklahoma City I think when all the smoke
steadily is gonna set back and say
staying home will be the best place for
confidence yeah go girl go Timmy after
what we did this year if you go
somewhere
either Oklahoma City stated the two
frontrunners
three thought he had the best chance to
win going forward and he clearly faces
all the state it won't be the famous
being the club driver and better being a
book writer and he said that you were
disappointed in his decision you still
feel that way yeah of course probably
even more I just would he ever played in
Oklahoma pity Guam view and then is the
weakest move I've ever seen from a
superstar stunned is the word a lot of
people are standing it's almost like a
reset button yes we ought to defend the
champions but at the same time this is
the new season you know it's up to us to
make sure we just continue on the
process
[Applause]
this is for you guys
the Golden State Warriors don't just eat
for success they aim for championships
you know a crowd like this they just
wait for something to happen I feel like
we're born every single day we don't
always keep rolling and keep getting
better at this point is muscle memory
for me but I'll tell him I'm gonna hit a
couple and I'm gonna look at him and let
him know that I'm locked in everyone
touches the ball everyone eat yeah
that's why I got like draymond Gregg to
give you 28 the playmakers they have
guys that can make plays make pass and
set others up
we have some huge aspirations and we
want to put ourself in a position to
compete for a championship and that's
all you can ask for we are who we are
you know we're all together we all have
each other's backs
and we're out on the floor that's how we
have to play that's been that way for
years and that won't change
[Applause]
this is the first time this season we're
going to see these two in the regular
season you expecting I'm expecting all
the fireworks we normally
is dealing with that warriors team
direct
gentleman mr. Wentzel party what
[Applause]
but now to have these two teams we have
a pass they have a history in the finals
two best teams in the NBA
well beyond
[ __ ] dolla sexist screens Iran delivers
and this equals the largest lead of the
game it's got a little quiet here in
Cleveland inside fights petroleum [ __ ]
James slaughter
it kinda reminds me a little bit of and
the Lakers in the South field made so
every year we couldn't wait for that
matchup Richard Jefferson to the main
roster town klay Thompson finds
Jefferson
the
for trade
[Music]
drives on Thompson Irving spin
puts up the shot
they throw it in the garage Durant
stumbles Falls
it's over
years down 14 here in the fourth quarter
come back and beat the Warriors 109 to
108